on the southern 215 belt we jammed up a
little bit around decatur that happens
just about every day
westbound on the 215 out of the 95 515
i11
right there around saint rose that gets
a little crowded and there is a crash
it looks like it is on i-15 but for now
we're going to take you up to a fatal
crash that took place a few hours ago
this is in the northwest valley you know
how us 95 travels north and you're
getting up towards the northern tiffany
beltway
you might remember there's the santa fe
station casino right there well the next
street over is rainbow
and rancho and low mountain and rainbow
all come together
so about three o'clock this morning
there was a fatal auto pedestrian crash
now the crash scene has been cleared got
a lot of investigators here so
northbound rancho is completely closed
south on rancho is open you recognize
that that's the parking garage for the
santa fe to try to get you acclimated to
what you're looking at here
they are going to d2 detour you back
onto rainbow or rancho because you won't
be able to get northbound there you can
work your way over to jones and keep
yourself posted on that one
may